what what y'all think about uh our boy
Dwight Howard free him bro he free
Dwight he didn't do nothing wrong free
Dwight yo did y'all see Ma's reaction
yes yo shout out to M and Cameron man I
mean they're just fantastic then they're
having a time in their lives I really
enjoy it because that's what that's what
I like coming here doing with y'all yeah
is just coming here and [__] laughing
how ridiculous we all are and you could
see the joy from cam when mace starts to
go off on a rant and he's just like I
known this [__] my whole life
this guy is so goddamn funny and uh when
he started doing the thing about listen
we gota we got to be honest here we say
all the time I don't care what you do in
your free time I don't care what you do
when you're by yourself we do care stop
lying stop lying we do care we do care D
white he called him D
white I did not know M was that funny y
this is the best thing for mace I ain't
like I knew cam was funny but I ain't
know mace was just funny that [__] was
hilarious he's like bro he has bits he
has bits he goes they're asking if it's
consensual a surprise is never
consensual yo it's like a funny line
like that's aoke that's what the guy is
I guess saying he's like he surprised
him someone's in the closet and they
popped down surprise him and he goes a
surprise is never consensual Dwight
that's the point of a
surprise like bro just so you just can't
have a guy pop out in a leprechaun
costume like
what n it's it's it's fantastic go check
it out anybody on team please hit them
up we would love that yeah we need we
need Mason cam bro we need Mason cam to
come by flavor and Dwight for that
matter can we get Dwight on yo we need
Dwight shout out to Dwight man do your
[__] thing yeah
M do your thing dang
Dwight D dang we saw Dwight at Burning
Man exactly and let the record show he
was with women the whole
time passion tips proba
miserable miserable it was the desert
bro it sunny you know I mean yeah now we
got to have Dwight on we got to talk
about all this [__] you was swapping
blunts with him right swapping spit no
you sure wait you shared a blunt with
him yeah I think he talked about on the
podcast yeah I remember you talking
about you you was like going passing the
back of for no what and you was like
get smoked up they talking about I want
to say do whatever you do cuz it's your
life and it's nobody else's business
that's true and we shouldn't Care thank
you but I care that you were
swapping bro he's
Superman Superman pass you a joint what
are you gonna do Superman passed you a
joint what are you gonna say at that
point he was Superman now he's the gay
guy not allegations are still there we
don't know anything yo first all there's
nothing wrong with being gay but I want
him to Double Down on that [__] I age
tell us he was smoking out chinan when
he was over there in Taiwan love it love
it yeah we would love that just be real
we just Y come we accept you Alex going
to let you crack back
CH yo let him make some espresso out of
you his H hero n no he's going to flick
your be going Tock but you you have your
nails painted bro don't matter he he
likes guys like you he don't want girly
[__] yes he does you can tell he likes a
guy like Al bro he want a man's man you
can tell he's a
Milkman he's a Milkman he want he wants
that Mark he want an espresso bro what
about both of y'all what about a little
latte oh he would love that pop out
let's
go we got you Dwight also use a promo
code Schultz you get your initial
deposit matched up to $100 that mean you
put in 100 you get a 100 for free so you
might as well just do it respect shout
out prize picks man